there are instances of cuttlefish
beautiful cephalopods like octopuses um
and that is the plural as we yeah um
the internet oh yeah that became a meme
or a little discussion yeah pretty quick
oh yeah and now we just resurfaced it
created the dismay in your voice is so
amusing
um in any event that the male cuttlefish
will disguise themselves by as female
cuttlefish infiltrate the female
cuttlefish uh
um group and then mate with them you
know
um all sorts of
um you know types of covert uh
operations so I think that
combat it's like a drinking game where
every time we say covert in a contract
in this uh episode you have to take a a
shot of espresso
um please don't do that you'd be dead by
the end
um so actually it's just a small tangent
it does make me wonder how much
intelligence covert contracts require it
seems like not much if they if we could
if you can do it in the animal kingdom
there's some kind of instinctual it is
based perhaps in like fear yeah it could
be um simple algorithm if if you know if
there's some ambiguity about numbers and
I'm not with these guys and you know
then flip to the alternate strategy I
actually have a story about this that I
think is relevant I used to have
cuttlefish in my lab in San Diego uh we
went and got them from a guy out in the
desert we put them in the lab it was
amazing and they had a postdoc who was
studying prey capture and cuttlefish
they have a very ballistic extremely
rapid strike and grab of the shrimp and
they um we were using high-speed cameras
uh to to characterize all this looking
at binocular they normally have their
eyes on the side of their head when they
see something they want to eat the eyes
translocate to the front which allows
them stereopsis death perception allows
them to strike we were doing some
unilateral eye removals they would miss
Etc okay
this has to do with eye spots this was
during a government shutdown period
where the ghost shrimp that they
normally
um feed on that we would ship in from
the Gulf down here
um weren't available to us so we had to
get different shrimp and what we noticed
was the the Cuttlefish normally would
just sneak up on the shrimp we learned
this by data collection and if the
shrimp was facing them they would do
this thing with their tentacles of kind
of enchanting the cuddle the the shrimp
and if the shrimp wasn't facing them
they wouldn't do it and they would
ballistically grab it and and eat them
well when we got these new shrimp the
new shrimp had eye spots on their tails
and then the Cuttlefish would do this
kind of attempt to enchant regardless of
the position of the ghost shrimp so what
does that mean okay well it means that
there's some sort of algorithm in the
cuttlefish's mind that says okay if you
see two spots move your tentacles so it
can be as you pointed out it can be a
fairly simple operation but it looks
diabolical it looks cunning but all it
is is strategy B
yeah but it's still somehow
emerged I mean I I I don't think that
it's calling it an algorithm doesn't I
feel like well there's a circuit there
that gets implemented in a certain
context but that circuit had to evolve
you do realize it super intelligent AI
will look at us humans and we'll say the
exact thing there's a circuit in there
that evolved to do this the algorithm a
and algorithm B and it's trivial and to
us humans it's fancy and beautiful where
I poetry about it but it's because so we
don't understand the subconscious
because they want that AI algorithm
cannot see into what it can't see it
doesn't understand the underworkings of
what allows all of this conversation
stuff to manifest and we can't even see
it how could AI see it maybe it will
maybe maybe AI will solve and give us
access to our subconscious maybe your AI
friend or coach like I think Andreessen
and others are are arguing is going to
happen at some point it's going to say
Hey you know Lex you're making decisions
lately that are not good for you but
it's because of this
algorithm that you picked up in
childhood that if you don't State your
explicit needs up front
you're not gonna get what you want so
why do it from now on you need to
actually make a list of every absolutely
outrageous thing that you want no matter
how outrageous and communicate that
immediately and that will work we're
talking about coefficient sexual
selection and then we went into some uh
where do we go well and you said you
were excited I was I was I was excited
well you were just saying what about
these these covert contracts and animals
do them I think it's simple contextual
engagement of a neural circuit which is
not just nerd speak for saying they do a
different strategy it's saying that
there has to be a circuit there
hardwired circuit maybe learned but
probably hardwired that can be engaged
right you can't build neural Machinery
out of in a moment
um you need to build that circuit over
time what is building it over time you
select for it the the Cuttlefish that
did not have that alternate context
driven circuit didn't survive when there
was a uh when all the shrimp that they
normally disappear here in the I spotted
shrimp showed up and there were a couple
that had some miswiring this is why
mutation right X-Men type stuff is real
um they had a mutation they had some
alternate wiring and that wiring got
selected before it became a mutation
that was adaptive as opposed to
maladaptive this is something people
don't often understand about genetics is
that it only takes a few generations to
devolve a trait make it worse but it
takes a long time to evolve an Adaptive
trait
there are exceptions to that but most
often that's true so a species needs a
lot of generations we are hopefully
still evolving as a species and it takes
a long time but to evolve more adaptive
traits but doesn't take long to to
devolve
adaptive traits so that you're getting
sicker or you're not functioning as well
so choose your mate wisely